seth davis of cbs and also turner sports
back here on the rich housing show how
you been seth
good to talk to you rich i guess the
super bowl's over yeah
to the big time guys now huh well i mean
and then and then just as football exits
stage left leaving the stage to uh
college basketball because the nba is on
its all-star break
my coach throws a hand in the handshake
line and uh all holy heck ensues what'd
you think of that and uh the suspension
that juan howard received seth well i
mean clearly it was most uh unfortunate
for jawan to lose his cool like that and
it's not the first time you know this
happened last year
when he
kind of went after mark turgeon uh the
then maryland coach and kind of had to
be restrained which
i've never seen
well i've never seen a coach do that i
mean
coaches jawing at each other in the
handshake line or getting kicked off at
each other or saying things is hardly
unusual but to have a coach need to be
physically restrained from going after
another coach and then um you know
landing a slap slash punch on another
coach i've never seen that and i think
in retrospect rich the school made a big
mistake and not coming down on juwon the
last time um and when you you know sort
of enable that type of behavior
then you're basically telling someone
hey as long as you win games you can get
away with a lot of things we saw that
for countless years down the road in
bloomington um i don't know juan howard
well uh you know he's a little uh hands
off with the media certainly i what i
when i've been around him i've liked him
very much i'm incredibly impressed by
him he's done an amazing job in michigan
he's an incredible asset in many many
ways for college basketball so i hope he
learned his lesson that um
he can't keep doing this and frankly i
think the school and the big ten got it
right i think five games is
very serious particularly this time of
year for a team that's on the tournament
bubble and fighting to play for its
postseason i think um you know anything
more than that firing him in my opinion
would have been excessive so hopefully
you know he learns from this and
and they can move on so i will ask you
uh the topic that was red hot 48 hours
ago but i'm having you on now so i'll
ask it now what do you think of the
conversation
uh sparked by what happened uh that the
handshake line should just be done away
with since it's a mere formality that is
now
being used to uh sort of like festivus
airing of grievances and then feats of
strength what do you think seth well
i'm very impressed with that old school
classical literature thank you sir i
gotta dust off my classics to come on
your show thank you sir um i i hate that
argument rich i love the handshake line
i'm a sportsmanship nerd i've got three
sons who are all playing sports my
oldest son is a high school senior they
got knocked out of the playoffs last
night a very painful way for his senior
year to end and they had a handshake
line and he had to shake hands with the
team that beat him and i like that um
and you know 99.99
of the time
the handshake lines are completely
uneventful so my take is that if you
can't handle the handshake line you
probably don't belong certainly in
college sports
i believe that athletics is education
and i believe that
you know if you lose a game you should
be mentally strong enough
to look your opponent in the eye shake
that person's hand and say
congratulations good game we'll try to
get you next time it's respect for your
opponent it's respect for the game and
i'm very much in favor seth davis here
of cbs sports and the athletic and so
much more here on the rich eisen show so
let's turn the page to wednesday night
um and michigan taking on
rutgers with phil martelly the old hand
from saint joe's and a lot of fans who
might have been wondering what where
phil went
um and then they tune in tonight they'll
be like oh yeah i remember that guy he
only won over 440 games for st joe's
right and
so he uh he's going to be the man there
in this unique position and part of what
i was you know disappointed one of the
many things i was disappointed in about
uh what juwan howard wrought by throwing
that hand is two players are now
suspended for a game
and uh we're we're seeing this this
this uh moment uh the handshake line uh
over and over and over again and it's
embarrassing more more and more times
that i see it
and this is a bubble team they flat out
14 and 11 needing every w they can get
here on out for the last five remaining
big ten regular season games what do you
think of
this position that michigan finds itself
in starting tonight seth well you know
one of those players musa diabate was
coming off a career-high 28 points uh in
a win over purdue i mean he he and he's
a very talented recruit a little bit raw
but you know it was funny watching funny
but it was fascinating watching that
game was like you could literally see
i'm like the light just went on with
this kid and they have a great center
and hunter dickinson who learned to step
away from the baskets so it's most
unfortunate and you know people may not
be aware but if you throw a punch it is
an automatic one-game suspension there's
no deliberation about that and again why
wouldn't you know why wouldn't he throw
a punch is head coach just told him it
was okay and you know physically so yeah
it's super unfortunate and they're
playing now it's good that they're in
ann arbor so that'll help um you know
maybe the pre-game meal or zimmerman's
can can get them going but
um they're playing a rutgers team that
is it's been an amazing story and they
play a very physical brand of basketball
in fact rich i didn't know this at the
time but because in what a lot of what
happened this emerged on on twitter but
when rutgers beat michigan
uh at rutgers the abate had to be
restrained at the end of that game um
and had to be kind of pulled into the
locker room because he was upset so you
know he's a kid he's playing his way
through it but michigan does not have a
ton of margin for error now i will say
that the committee does take into
account these things you know with
personnel injuries or someone's out for
covet or in a couple of games where
teams didn't have their head coach so if
michigan is like right right on the
bubble and they lose this game
um the committee has the latitude to say
um well they didn't have their starting
power for forward and they didn't have
their head coach
but there's only so far that's going to
take at some point you got to win enough
games and that's what michigan is up
against right now yeah i mean illinois i
mean who would love to stick to dagger
and more than izzo and michigan state
right um in a couple of games
uh a visit to the ohio state i i can't
forget the v uh to to finish up it's it
it's not an easy road brutal lake they
could go on five the rest of the way and
that would make
the decision very easy for the
basketball committee how dare your seth
how how dare you i'm sorry number four
out of five if you're at home no i no i
and i and i know that so uh who else uh
seth davis here on the rich eisen show
who else is on that bubble uh
of of teams that are
have been successful recently or long
term who else do you think uh is
endangered well you know the one that
really comes to mind is is north
carolina who's very quietly had a very
very um disappointing year hubert davis
is first
right now they only have one
quad one win
um and that's that's hard to get into
the tournament with that i remember in
the old rpi days it was top 50 wins and
i always felt like the magic number was
three if you were a bubble team and you
have three top 50 wins because the
import the good wins
are
have i think greater weight than bad
losses every bubble team has bad losses
that's why rutgers
is a fascinating case because they have
a ton of bad losses but also a lot of
really
really
um good wins five quad one wins for
rutgers so uh you know carolina's up
against it indiana is up against it um
you know the question of whether or not
uh the big ten can get nine teams
because the acc is probably only going
to have three i mean we could have a
situation where the mountain west and
the west coast conference
both have more teams in this tournament
than the acc i don't think either of us
thought we'd live long enough to see
that but it's been it's been that kind
of season in college basketball can you
explain to people what the hell a quad
one one is
can you do that thank you that's a great
nerd question what the hell what is it a
quad one went so so where does it come
from who who decides what's a what what
what does that mean everything i decide
everything i make every actually that
would if i decided everything there
would be zero replays in any sports
that's a conversation for another day so
people and you see the rpi
rank right now they change that to what
they call the net ranking which uses the
more predictive analytic models the rpi
was a little bit um
out of date so you know
scoring margin comes in a little into
effect but people misread it because
they say you know what a team's overall
ranking in the net is not relevant it's
what they do
against
other teams right okay so
so and they also wanted to um make home
in a way a factor so a quad one wins yes
is it is a win over a team or or lost a
quad one game if you're at home the
opponent is ranked one through 30 in the
net if it's a neutral court the opponent
is top 50 in the net and if it's a road
game it's top 75 in the net and then so
quad 2 home 31 75 neutral 51 to 100 away
76 to 135 so it's just it's an
organizing tool because this 25 and 2
team is obviously not the same as this
25 and 2 teams so how do you quantify
that that's where all these numbers
and quad and quad is well it's just a
college campus term quad like
i'm serious i'm fascinated by this stuff
who decides this is like is like
lennardi drops some peyote and then
hangs out with a bunch of people and
they shot gun beers yeah leonardi peyote
is a great fantasy team named chris
brockman's writing it down right now
honestly who decides this stuff
there's a there's a committee the same
committee that selects the the
tournament yes quadrants by the way so
it's quad one quad two quad three quad
four rods don't want any quad four
quadrant yes okay very good okay um i
don't know what a quad is for i guess if
it's a four-sided
piece of grass i guess
yeah sure right yes right right i wasn't
smart enough again for instance for
instance for instance seth uh on when i
was at school i had i had no quad one
wins i had no wins in any quad it was
terrible
that's why i wrote for the student
newspaper
that's right it's been helpful i had no
quad wins no quad one week
we could get if we're getting
competitive we could get into jewish
[Laughter]
did we ever battle an inter-camp game
seth davis is that your no okay were you
we were you trails and remind me that
was trail zen yeah where were you well
then
equinox
oh
i was keeping score seth
oh how old am i i'm 51. so we this
happened you and i have played anderson
camp games before we actually have okay
somewhere and it can't be your book
because me talking on you on the video
so somebody comes up with this and these
metrics are then agreed to and then and
then what the the same men's basketball
committee that selects and sees the
bracket they oversee a lot of the
administration
of the ncaa tournament not just the the
bracketing and so this is just a
conversation over the years about how
best
really to take out the subjectivity
because it's because once you start
getting subjective now it's like well
who are your buddies with and what
conference are you in and are you a high
major and are you know this this eye
test thing is is silly
um and then it's also about um valuing a
non-conference schedule like they
they're trying to incentivize
um these high major teams to play good
games in november and december because
otherwise if you're in a power league
you could just play lousy teams at the
start of the year and then know you're
going to get enough opportunities for
quality wins so um you know it's been a
conversation for total basketball nerds
uh and then you know people who want to
see this thing done well and fairly and
and and that's where we landed well i
just want to make sure my pay attention
to all that and i'll let you know what
you need to know i don't want you that's
what that's sort of that's what i'm
saying so so i guess just to wrap up
this conversation what's a good number
when i'm seeing you and everybody else
talk about this and this team has these
quad one wins what's a good number of
wins somebody wins to have when you're
on the bubble
so if you're a bubble team i would say
three quad one wins is probably
important it's not it's not make or
break right so some of these mid major
teams um are not going to have that like
murray state is a top 25
uh i don't think they're going to be
able to get three quad one wins but
they're also not going to have any bad
losses so okay um it's tough i mean you
know they're sitting in that committee
room 10 men and women and making these
decisions and there's a lot on the line
these kids have worked hard and there's
a there's money at stake and
uh you know you want to find some way to
level the playing field and look at the
data in the best
in the way that's most reflective and
then just do the best you can and know
that you're going to get ripped either
way that's kind of like hosting a talk
show
either way you might as well say what
you want to say
or enter camp games in uh in the in the
pennsylvania poconos like we did back in
the day if people if people think that
like you know the nfl playoffs was
exciting i mean oh yeah they don't know
what it can't get they have like no idea
pennsylvania
that's what it was seth davis let's do
this again shortly you'll look for my
call back i love talking to you thank
you right back at you that's seth davis
cbs sportsy athletic and more right here
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here